radio giant has or is signing off this
morning after a legendary career 70 year
old Tom Joyner is the host of America's
number one syndicated urban morning show
the Tom Joyner Morning Show airs in more
than 105 markets nationwide reaching
nearly 8 million listeners today at
10:00 a.m. Eastern the show goes off the
air unbelievable
John Ricca Duncan's here she travelled
to Hollywood Florida to meet the hardest
working man in radio tarika how does it
feel about hanging up the mic well you
know it's bittersweet for Tom Joyner
this is a man who admits he has made a
lot of money in radio but he has also
raised a lot of money to support
historically black colleges more than 60
million dollars to be exact it's clear
Joyner loves his job and he loves the
listeners who have been supporting him
for the last 25 years
[Music]
Tom Joyner keeps his listeners laughing
and learning Hillary the first black
woman is standing on both the north and
south pole our thing has always been to
empower people but to empower we have
the first entertain if I've got you
laughing I've got you listening his
nationally syndicated radio show hit the
airwaves in 1994 with a certain audience
in mind we do a show for for African
Americans that's what we do this is this
so fast in 2000 Joyner discussed his
influence with 60 minutes correspondent
Lesley Stahl 1996 the election yeah I've
heard that you were responsible for
registering a quarter of a million black
voters I've been given that credit
politicians they call you come on yeah
they think that if they want to reach
african-americans that vote that guy
they can come to this
how does the message that you were
talking about in 2000 resonate with 2019
we go into the 2020 election it was
different than I think we're more woke
then than now in 2000 in 2000 what day
Joyner says super serving the
african-american community has been the
secret to his success
don't worry about crossover just super
serve Super serve super serve anything
that affects African Americans that's
what you do just worry about connecting
to people and their needs he was born
and raised in Tuskegee Alabama one of
many cities that helped shape the civil
rights movement I was a [ __ ] here and
they serve great food and civil rights
marches oh my god that chicken was good
so I'm out there protesting the fact
that our radio station and that's all
black town didn't play any black music
and this guy who owned the radio station
which was inside a Ford dealership came
out and said I don't need this I'm
trying to really sell some cars
tell you what it's a sunup to sundown
station every Saturday I'll let one of
you play all the Aretha and the
temptations that you want that's how it
started that's how it started by the mid
1980s Joyner earned a nickname fly jock
that's because he was offered two jobs
and took both flying between Dallas
where he did a morning show and Chicago
where he was on air in the afternoons
how did you do that for eight years
though Green celebrities including Oprah
Winfrey have been calling in to
congratulate Joyner on his retirement
congratulations
without you
Sybil Wilkes co-host the show with
Joyner from Dallas the Tom Joyner
Morning Show has been a lifeline for a
lot of people who are going through
their day to day but it has empowered
them it's entertained entertainment and
empowerment have paid off at its peak
Joyner says he was making 14 million
dollars a year but it got too
where they were he's gonna cut your
salary in half okay and then in half
okay and then in half two years ago
because my salary was based on my
results and and not only was I losing
affiliates but radio industry as a whole
was losing traction if you had been
offered more money would you have stayed
longer yeah sure
my goal was to die on the radio have my
funeral on the radio what's the next
chapter I'm just gonna be concentrating
on raising money I'm putting putting it
into the hands of college students to
help their tuition at historically black
colleges that's my goal all after 12:00
noon so we won't be waking up so after
the noon hour that's right I'm not going
to bed at 3 o'clock in the mouth joiners
advice to his successor Rickey smiley
super served the african-american
community and community and continue to
give back you know this is somebody that
I grew up listening to when I was in
Cleveland and then again when I was in
Philadelphia and I actually interned
under one of his competitors so we
talked about that in the interview but
just a really phenomenal person who
again is not shy about saying yeah I did
make money yeah but I also gave a lot of
money he did build an empire yeah and he
hit on so many different issues I mean
he went through a great weight loss and
also Fitness period of his life and he
brought a lot of attention to that to a
community that suffers from diabetes
yeah I love that super serval yeah also
if you got them laughing you got them
listening device from Dallas to Chicago
thank you thank you very much